ce groupe de marcheurs est adepte des
chemins de Compostelle ce sont des
puristes puisqu'ils font le pèlerinage à
pied comme au Moyen-Âge au total 1700 km
au départ de vandô dans le loircher
toute la logistique tient dans une seule
cariol fixé par un Harn sur l'un des
marcheurs le parcours balisé par
l'association Compostelle 41 mentionne
toutes les chapelles portant la marque
de
Saint-Jacques c'est un chemin de
rencontre
en voiture on pas le temps de se causer
on n pas le temps de se voir de discuter
à pied on rencontre plein de gens on a
on se pose on prend le temps c'est
surtout ça je suis pas croyante mais
j'ai eu besoin de ça ce pélerinage pour
me ressourcer pour me retrouver moi-même
parce que c'était une une recherche de
moi-même parce que j'allais pas bien et
donc ça a été vraiment très
salvateur grâce à ça c'est j'étais en
borne haute et ça m'a
sauvé les chemins qui va les mener
jusqu'à château Renaud en indréloire
l'association a repris les coutumes des
pèlerins du Moyen-Âge comme ce point de
ravitaillement ce
ch ah bah on peut boire un coup là ils
sont sympas ils nous ont offert de l'eau
on trouve comme ça sur le bord du chemin
des gens qui offrent de l'eau ou un café
ou du thé quelque foois les gens sont
pas là mais ils mettent à disposition
donc c'est très
bien sur la route de Compostelle terme
du voyage la prochaine étape pour ces
pèlerins c'est tour à raison de 45 km
par jour ils mettront près de 24
he